سلسله غارات على عدد من مدن قطاع غزه
شنتها المقاتله الاسرائيليه بينها الشرق
خان يونس جنوبي القطاع وفي شماله وشرقه في
بيت لاهيا تحديدا وشرق مخيم البريج وسط
غزه وشمال غرب بيت حانون تحدث الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن استهداف اكثر من مئه منشاه
عسكريه في القطاع واكثر من اربعين منصه
لاطلاق الصواريخ بالمقابل قصفت فصائل
المقاومه مناطق عديده وجددت قصفها في
منطقه غلاف غزه فيستيروت وانحلعوز ومناطق
اخرى ودوت سفره الانذار في عسقلان والنقب
الغربي وبئر السبع واسود ومحيطها على بعد
30 كيلومترا من الحدود مع غزه سمعت ايضا
اصوات انفجارات جنوبي تل ابيب اثر اعتراض
القبه الحديديه صواريخ وصلت الى بيت شيمش
غربيه القدس ودوت صافره الانذار في مناطق
اخرى كما كان لافتان تسبب اطلاق فصائل
المقاومه لصواريخها في تعطيل حركه الطيران
في مطار بن غوريون وفقا لبيانات الم لاحيه
بمعرقله واقلاع الطائرات المدنيه بالمطار
استعدادا لاطلاق الصواريخ بمدايات اكبر او
عز وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي بتوسيع دائره
الطوارئ حول غزه لتصل الى 80 كيلومترا
وبالمجمل تحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي عن نحو
400 صاروخ اطلقت من قطاع غزه كما اشار الى
تصدي منظومه مقلاع داوود المضاده للصواريخ
الباليستيه لصاروخ اطلق نحو تل ابيب